>>> TONIGHT WE'RY GETTING
ASE VENTS HIEN HOUSE REPUBLICAN
LES HAS DETAILS.eporter: HOUPE
LEADEV McCARTHY HAS HAD
EN ON A HOT MIKETELLING A FONE
REALLY THINKLIZ CHEN SHE'S GL P.
I'VE LOST CONFCEeporter: THETEW
S A CLEAR
WYOMING COERSHIP ARERE A FEW MO
DEFENDED CHENEY FROMHE
BASH OF MEMBERS ANGRY
TO T TRUMP.
HERE TALKT
SMALL BUSI.  NOW McCARTHY SEEM
FAR S TAKE CHENEY  HER ROLE AS
RANKING HOUSE REPUBLICAN.
>> I HAVE HEARD FREMBERS
CONCERNED ABOUT HER ABILITY TO
CHR,T THE
WE ALL NEED TO BE WORKING AS O
MAJORITY.
r: MLE
EMSW, REFUSING TO LIE AB
TRUMP.
THIS IS R THE AN PARTY IRPETUAT
WHPEARY thh.
R SPOKESPERSONL
NODO THAT,IS ISSUECH MEETINGIT
S JUST TOO MUCFOR HE
WHAT H JANUARY 6th IS A
IS ALREADY UNDERWAY.D.THE JOCKE
JIM RRENTLCHAIRS
E IS BEING CONSIDERED.
KENSON O A
PROMINENT MEMBER OF THE
CONSERVATI FREEDOM
CRS E SEDRAMA, HOUSE NANCY PELOE
FEMALE SEEKING REPLACEME FOR PU
VOT CONVICT  HIS LASIMPEAC DEF
RO LIE.
TOA MEOF A GROUP THAPUNISHED SOE
LLOWING THEIE AS THE T
RANKING HOUS
BE COMING TO AN END AS S
VOTE CE  NT TIME CONFERENCE MEE
ON MAY 12th.
HAPPENING BECAUSE EYUSED TY INT
THE
IO
AN
JOHN KASICN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR MI
PU CONGRESS.
JAMIE, YOU'RHEOUD,
S EARLY ASEXT
WEEK.
THRENING.
>> EXACTLY THAT KEVI
HE THE VOTESATDONE DEAL AND THY
THE VOTE ODA
th
REPLAC, THAT HAS OTHER PEOPLNG F
A
SOURCEHABO A OF EVY H LIZ  OUT
THIS.
I QUOTE, THAT Z ENEYS  ALL N RI
RAE CONSEQUENCES.
SOURCE TOLD
AND FINALL WOLF, I'M TOLD LI W .
W
>> WE'LLENS WITH F THIS REP ESR
>> WELL,ALL,
E LEADERSHIP IN THE
REPUANAR IT EXACTL
WILLY WONKA'S GOLDENIT'RNU THREE
PERSON IN SH
WHAT THEY DON'T SEEMO LCULATE I
SHE
NSTAKE HER THEY COUL AND REMPLA.
SHE'S NO G.
INDED PEOPLE IN
NOT GOING R PLE WHFOLLOWING ANMT
.
WE HAVE A LONG TO GO BEFORE  PL
THAT THAU'RE NOT DOING
YOURSELF ULTIMATELY MORE HARM
WHATIL LOVE, WHAT'S YOURONSE TWI
THE HOUSE REPLEAD WOULDE
I MEAN CHENEY,HO T RANKING FEMAN
SH IS THE ONLY WOMAN P.
YOU'RE GOING T HER
THEN THIS IDEAT WE WAN
PLAC WOMANIS QUITEVE.
IT'SF N ONLY IF  E
AAYING, WARG TO
EL
E ERICAN
PEOPLE AREETTING.
IT DOESN'T LOOK GOOD
GOP.
THEY SD,FOCUS T OF CONTROLPE O
FOT THAT'S NOTHA'RE G EACH
RANKING
REPUBLICAN WOMAN IN THPUBLIC LEI
RLY NCE GHN IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
JAO YO
%.OOF THN THARTY?
THIS IS WHAT DONALD TRUM
TARGEZ CHENEY FOR GOINGHI
BIDDING.
I IT'S IMPTAPO
McCARTHAR
N, A FRINGE
COMMIT
ASSIGNMENTS, BUT HE IS PUSHING
OUT LIZ CHENEYE OFNSERVATIVEEPT
>>?
>>IRALL,
PARTY IN
THAT SHE SAID WHAT
HAPPENED ONULE, SHE'S GOT A LO H
SO MUCH TO T TAXMADE,
SPEND ANTHEY'RE
ONHEIN ART TO HAVE PURITY.A IN'
GOING ON DOWN THERE.I THINK JAM.
, THESKE
COPS MAY ENDP WITHE
MAJORITY BACK AN THEY'LL